it's been quite the journey but wanda
vision has reached its final episode
what began as a love letter to classic
tv slowly transformed into a tale of
confusion
betrayal grief and more here's how
wandavision wrapped up its small screen
tenure and what the finale means for the
mcu's future
after holding wanda's twin sons hostage
and forcing her to relive her past
trauma agatha continues her pursuit of
wanda's power
as noted in last week's episode wanda is
apparently the legendary scarlet witch
a being capable of unmatched creation
and destruction
so naturally agatha is prepared to go to
great lengths to take wanda's chaos
magic for herself
the two battle in the series finale
using their abilities against one
another but wanda is effectively
powerless
every time she tries to fight back
against agatha the ancient witch
absorbs the energy for herself this
leads wanda to get crafty
witchcrafty if you will sneaking up from
behind and using the mind control trick
she used back in her first appearance in
2015's avengers age of ultron
her illusion sends agatha back to the
day she killed off her witch coven
though the seasoned magic user quickly
turns the spell around on her
in response wanda breaks it and takes
the fight to agatha directly
before seemingly giving up and handing
over her chaos magic willingly
her body turns dark and withered and
agatha gains the strength she desires
but wanda has one more trick up her
sleeve
wanda reveals that she placed runes on
the interior walls of the hex
and regains the life force it seemed
agatha had drained from her
just as agatha taught her only the witch
who cast them
can use their magic in a confined space
this gives her the chance to reabsorb
her power
and take the form of the scarlet witch
overpowering her enemy
defeated and desperate agatha pleads
with wanda to no avail forced to live
out her days
in her chatty alter ego agnes it's rare
for villains to outlive their
introduction in the mcu
so it's pretty much a given that agatha
will return somewhere down the line in
fact it seems almost like a guarantee
you're gonna need me if i do
i know where to find you the only
question left now is just how soon we'll
see her again
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness or somewhere further down the
line
a major surprise came at the tail end of
wandavision's eighth episode
unveiling sword's white vision for the
first time the synthezoid spectre got
the chance to show off what he can do
this week
nearly crushing wanda's skull and going
head-to-head with the hex-bound vision
of her creation
the majority of the two visions
confrontation gives longtime marvel fans
the kind of
laser beam shooting hand-to-hand action
they've been waiting for but not for
long
after clashing for a short while the
visions share an
intellectual debate concerning the
nature of their existence
levitating inside west view's library
vision presents
white vision with the ship of theseus
thought experiment
the theory asks that if the ship's
rotting pieces are continually replaced
over time does the
ship eventually cease to exist since its
original form will eventually be
depleted
i request elaboration they apply that
question to themselves
noting that westview's vision lacks a
physical form but contains the vision's
soul
and white vision retains the original
synthetic body and memories filed away
as data
in his memory story but doesn't have the
vision's personality therefore
are either of them truly vision neither
is the true ship
both of the drew shiv to put this debate
to bed
the wanda created vision unlocks his
doubles memories
who has realized that the knowledge of
his true self was being suppressed by
hayward in order to make him
a weapon to be more easily controlled
with his data restored
the white vision leaves westview and
disappears for the rest of the series
finale but it's safe to assume that
he'll make his return in a future mcu
project
when and whether or not he'll attempt to
reconnect with wanda are questions only
time can answer
in the midst of their magic slinging
confrontation
agatha begins to play some serious mind
games with wanda
this includes her awakening a handful of
west views residents
leading them to surround wanda and beg
for mercy
they say they share in her pain and
either want to be freed or die
because the suffering that comes with
living under her trance is unbearable
this causes wanda to panic so she opens
the hex and allows the people to escape
her clutches that is until she notices
vision
philly and tommy disintegrating as their
existences
are tied to the hex later on with agatha
defeated and the hex completely wiped
from westview
the town's people still seem to hold
plenty of ill will toward wanda
shooting her the stink eye on her way
out of the community thankfully
jimmy wu and an fbi task force show up
to help the now freed residents
but that doesn't absolve wanda of her
wrongdoings
she held an entire town against their
will and unwittingly caused them real
harm for quite a long time
that's something that doesn't go away in
the blink of an eye and wanda's guilt
will likely last just as long as the
psychological damage she caused for
every one of them chances seem good that
we'll be hearing about west view again
in a future mcu project soon just as the
consequences of the battles in zakovia
and lagos reverberated after avengers
age of ultron and captain america civil
war
after it briefly appeared in wanda
vision's seventh installment breaking
the fourth wall
viewers finally got a good look at
agatha's magical book the darkhold
that's the book of the damned the
longtime witch
first mentions it by name in the series
finale telling wanda that the darkhold
contains an entire chapter devoted
solely to the scarlet witch
a powerful sorceress who defies the
usual rules of witchcraft
agatha notes that it's wanda's destiny
to destroy the world
this moment must have piqued wanda's
interest as she's
shown reading the so-called book of the
damned in the show's final post-credits
scene
unsurprisingly the dark hold is a
storied artifact from the pages of
marvel comics
dating back to 1972's marvel spotlight
number four
where it's described as a collection of
spells and techniques of dark magic
over the years the darkhold has had many
owners including the sorceress morgan
lafaye
who bound it from a collection of
parchments into the unholy book it would
become
and even the sorcerer supreme dr
strength
considering both wanda's devotion to
understanding the darkhold's knowledge
and dr strange's comic history as one of
its previous owners
it's a safe bet that the darkhold is
coming with her when she shows up in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
and given the fact that she hears her
kids crying for help as she reads
through the book in the scene's final
moments
there's a pretty good chance she'll seek
out the good doctor's help so she can
rescue them from whatever dimension
they may now be trapped within as marvel
comics fans may recall
billy and tommy are revealed to be
shards of a demon's soul in 1989's
avengers west coast number 52.
could the mcu's take on wanda's powerful
progeny be trapped in hell itself
of course devoted fans know that this
isn't the first time we've seen the
darkhold in the mcu
its first screen appearance was actually
in season 4 of agents of shield
there it was established that the shape
changing book has long been a powerful
artifact in the mcu
and it wound up playing a large role in
the phil coulson-led team's dealings
with the newest version of ghost rider
among other shenanigans it next appeared
in the late lamented hulu original
runaways
and was wielded by the evil sorceress
morgan lafaye
just how the book ended up in agatha's
possession or even if marvel studios
will recognize its previous appearances
in the now defunct marvel television
productions remains to be revealed
after a week away from the one division
spotlight monica rambo
had a bit more to do in the series
finale not only did monica take down
agatha's fake take on quicksilver who's
neither a recast version of the mcu
pietro
nor the x-men version from a different
universe instead
he's actually just some guy named ralph
boner
boner but monica
also got to test out her burgeoning
powers with the hex down
director hayward and his sword cronies
burst on the scene
when hayward fires his gun at wanda's
kids billy and tommy
monica steps in she uses her phasing
abilities to alter her physiology
thus stopping the bullets from hitting
the twins
with the help of darcy lewis hayward is
apprehended and his plan
is spoiled leaving jimmy wu and monica
rambo to clean up westfield in the first
of the wanda vision finale's
two post-credits scenes a sword agent
ushers monica
into the local movie theater to speak
with her revealing herself to be a
scroll
the agent mentions that an old friend of
monica's mother maria rambo
sent her and wants to arrange a meeting
when asked where
the scroll then points upward indicating
that their conversation will take place
in space
could this be a follow-up to the end
credit scene from spider-man far from
home where nick fury is shown sitting
comfortably aboard a massive
scroll-filled spacecraft or is the
skrull referring to the return of talos
alternatively is this a setup for
monica's inclusion in captain marvel 2
via a reunion with carol danvers time
will tell but it's clear that monica's
story is far from over
in keeping with the series of unending
tragedies that has won to maximoff's
life
her perfect fictional world finally
comes crashing down
at the end of the one division series
finale with agatha defeated
the people of west view freed and sword
as well as the fbi on her case
wanda is left no other choice but to
take down the hacks
streets and shops begin returning to
their natural state
and the time of day once again matches
the outside world
the disintegrating hex closes in on the
family
and wanda knows it's inevitable that
billy tommy and vision will disappear
from existence
before that happens the family returns
home after a long day of battle
begrudgingly prepared to bid one another
farewell
first wanda and vision tucked their
twins into bed
and she thanks them for choosing her as
their mother as the hex's borders
draw nearer wanda and vision then enter
the living room to say their final
goodbyes to vagina
wanda reveals this vision exists thanks
to the elements of the mind stone
that live inside of wanda they embrace
with the synthezoid predicting that
much like before they'll meet again
someday in some form
he then disappears leaving wanda alone
once again
on the plot of land where they once
planned to build their home on paper
wanda vision is a tough sell it's about
a powerful witch
who crafts a fake reality to avoid
properly grieving the loss of her true
love
who was previously killed twice several
movies ago
couple that with wanda and visions
super-powered children
the recast pietro maximoff the people
wanda took hostage
agatha's whole deal in general sword's
status as mostly good guys but
also partially bad guys and the weird
factor only increases
even still the cast and crew involved
managed to turn this risky premise into
something truly special
wanda vision made fans laugh cry and
everything in between
and is sure to spark conversation and
debate for a good long time to come
if this is the level of quality viewers
can expect from marvel studios disney
plus offerings
then the mcu's future is very bright
indeed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you